BLADE KOTELLY: So the
class is broken up
into two sessions, a Monday
and a Wednesday class.
Each class is two hours long.
The typical class runs where at
the beginning of the semester,
there'll be more lecture
than towards the end.
JOEL SCHINDALL: Blade and
I have developed a style
for teaching the course
which works very well for us.
It's a bit like Our
Town where the actors go
through their paces, and
every once in awhile they stop
and the stage manager
comes on stage
and makes an
editorial comment that
couldn't be conveyed
in a direct fashion.
We evolved it perhaps
because Blade is charismatic.
He is very effective at
the teaching of the course.
He knows the material.
He lives the material.
But I've had a lot of the
experiences in industry
about how this material
actually plays out.
So typically Blade will do
the bulk of the instructing
in a very Socratic
manner, which is
part of what makes
the class effective.
Blade is very, very good at
evoking from the students
their ideas about
what is design.
Meanwhile, I will
listen to the progress.
And where Blade touches
on a subject which
can be enhanced or embellished
by talking about real world
experience relating to
that particular topic,
I'll chime in.
Blade is wonderful about
stopping just about
in mid-sentence and allowing me
to work with the students just
a little bit to engage
them on this, to share
with them about it.
And then I go back and sit
down, and Blade continues right
where he left off.
BLADE KOTELLY: The lectures are
interspersed with activities.
So students will do some
hands-on activities every,
let's say, half hour.
Probably at the limit is about
halfway through, about an hour
through, they'll have to do
something no matter what.
Because you want to keep
students' attention up.
There'll be some classes
which are, like I said,
primarily lecture-based.
Some classes where it's a lot
of students working in groups,
and then we're stopping the
work, asking a question,
sharing ideas,
and evaluating it.
Some classes run in
a very Socratic way.
So we're really having
them come to conclusions.
So a class on
ethics, for example,
runs better when you
teach it Socratically
because they need to become
engaged with the material.
And if you're just
saying, here are
examples of ethical problems.
And here are their solutions.
They can check the box.
OK, yes I get that.
That makes sense to me.
Or maybe there's something
where they don't quite get it,
and you could bring up some
interesting discussions.
But I think it's more successful
to have them think about it
and be able to then
even argue in class.
And so you find
divergent points,
and you have different
students hash them out.
And you'll find that
sometimes other students will
come in having
turned their brain on
and being sparked by an
idea and say, wait a second.
No, no.
I think they're right.
And because we use
name cards that
have the name on the
front and the back,
the students can see
each other's name
and can say, you know, what
Joyce said was really good.
No, I like that.
That was an important point.
Basically they can
see each other.
So it connects a class
to be able to start
learning together, which makes
the learning process actually
very important for those kinds
of classes to be in person.
The class is meant to
have a lot of interaction.
As much as possible, really.
At the end of a big school
day, from 3:00 to 5:00 PM,
they could be tired.
And they probably stayed
up really late the night
before so they're
probably definitely tired
around that time.
So you want to make sure that
you're keeping them entertained
and engaged with the material.
I mean, it's really-- every
class has great material.
Any class can have
great material,
but the attitude, I think, is
that if you get your students
to be engaged intellectually,
they'll learn it faster.
Then when you're trying
to shift their thinking,
you're not just simply
explaining a concept,
but having them
think differently.
Then you need to
engage them even more,
because you need to change
the way their brains are
functioning and get synapses
to fire even differently.
JOEL SCHINDALL: We bring
in outside speakers
for some of the talks.
And the outside speakers
are an eclectic mix.
In some cases, we'll bring in
someone from the Engineering
faculty who is particularly
gifted at communicating
mechanical engineering
design skills
or electrical or
chemical, because we
want to give the
students-- there tend
to be some discipline
unique ways of thinking,
and we want to give the
students an idea of what
the broad range is.
But other times we
bring in someone
who seems rather off-the-wall.
We brought in someone
who has started
two or three restaurants
in the Boston Area.
And you say, a restaurateur?
What does that have to
do with engineering?
And the students
come to the class,
but don't really expect
to get anything of value
until they find out that
designing a restaurant
is a really significant
design process.
You have to look at
what do the users want?
How do you greet them
at the restaurant?
What type of food do you have?
How do you design the space?
How do you make the patron in
the restaurant feel welcome?
How do you make the staff
function effectively?
There are many, many aspects.
And to see someone in front
of the room who is not
an engineer, and
yet who is using
some of the same
engineer thinking
that you use to solve a
problem that you never thought
much about, because when
you go to a restaurant
you just hope that the food will
come and that it'll taste good
and that it won't
be too expensive
and that your favorite
dish will be there.
But you tend not to
pay any attention
to how were you
greeted by the hostess?
How were you seated?
What are the wait staff doing?
How is the cook
working in the kitchen?
And you begin to
realize that there
are many more
dimensions in the world
that you're interacting with
than you pay attention to.
BLADE KOTELLY: If we have a quiz
in class, we administer a quiz,
we swap all the quizzes,
we review all the answers.
Quizzes tend to have a lot
of the questions repeated
on each quiz so if they didn't
know the answer the first time,
they should know
it the second time.
And they'll definitely
know it the third time.
Because we review it in class.
We'll spend several
minutes reviewing
that quiz to make sure students
can use it as a learning
opportunity, because I do
want to do a diagnostic to see
what are they getting?
Are they doing the reading?
I want them to do the reading.
It's how I test for it.
But I also want to make
sure that they're learning.
And if they haven't
done the reading,
maybe they learn a
little bit from this,
maybe they'll ask some
different questions.
So we'll have someone grade
and then give the result
to see what the contour
of the grades are.
Even though they've already
swapped papers and done
their own grading, students go
through and check all of them
again so they can understand
what the contour is
so I can understand are students
not reading the book yet?
Maybe we assigned
the book too soon
and they weren't able to get
to the bookstore soon enough.
Or maybe they're in
a real crunch time,
they weren't able to review
some of the material.
So we try to do a diagnostic
to see what's happening.
The teaching assistants
will take notes,
one teaching assistant
will take notes
during class of everything
that we discussed
so we can tune out the
slides and topics later on.
The may be an example that we
haven't used before that either
is topical, because now a
company releases a new product
that we want to be
able to incorporate.
Or there'll be a new way
to articulate something.
They'll say, oh, that's
a really good way
that we were able to
articulate this idea.
Or a really good moment
that happened here in class.
Let's think about how to bring
that into the curriculum.
So we're always taking
notes about each class.